There!
Zero casualties!
Idea of the game, three in a row.
Good luck Emil!
Good luck!
First shot!
Good first shot!
Ooh that was close!
This is actually pretty intense!
Still no pops!
Hit the middle one, that's the best one to hit.
It hit the side of the, yeah it hit the side.
I'll start the game now.
Okay start playing!
It touched!
It touched the balloon!
But it didn't pop.
Bullseye!
Okay that looked pretty cool!
That looked pretty cool!
It felt pretty cool!
The playing field has been opened.
Boom!
It's a pretty good spot.
Okay that was unexpected.
Middle pink is what I'm going for.
Boom!
That's a good one for me!
Now all I need is the yellow one.
I'll have to aim for that one next.
This is where the game gets interesting.
Matchpoint!
Yeah it is.
Aaah that was really bad!
More of those please!
Almost two!
It hit also the one next to it!
I was so nervous!
It would have been three in a row.
So the one who gets that, wins.
The deciding one.
There, there there!
That was really close!
There there there that's good!
Yes, neither one popped.
It bounced on two!
It's got very intense.
That's, no...
Oh no!
That missed completely.
Three circles, Emil takes the game!
And guys there is still 76% of you guys who
haven't subscribed so help us out and do it now!
Until next time!
No no, don't do it!
Does it look even remotely as a circle?
Otto: No.
We need all same...